alor baronou bonjour merci de nous
recevoir chez vous pour moi vous êtes
une une personnalité évelinoise orors du
commun vous avez eu un métier qui n'est
pas courant suivi de d'engagement aussi
originaux et et différents de ce qu'on
peut voir d'habitude alors moi
j'aimerais bien que vous me racontiez
pour commencer votre votre métier quel
était-il là et bien j'étais reporteur
photographe pendant environ 15 20 ans je
me suis baladée un petit peu on va dire
de par le monde pour faire des sujets
d'ordre un petit peu généraux voilà
alors généraux ça veut dire quoi généux
ça veut dire que ça pouvait aller des
trafiquants d'armes à Dara à la
frontière de l'Afghanistan jusqu'à la
dame qui s'estcardé les poils de chien
pour faire des pulls pour les dames
voilà qui ont des toutousc voilà donc
toujours dans l'humain finalement vous
avez toujours été en contact des
population et et votre comment dire
votre plaisir de photographe est-ce que
vous avez fait des photos un petit peu
différentes de Cell qu'on vous
commandait pour le
reportage oui alors je me suis rendu
compte oui alors je faisais d'abord mes
photos de reportage le travail le
travail en effet et puis en dehors
souvent je chois pour pour mon plaisir
et c'est il n'y a pas très longtemps
enfin pas très longtemps ça fait quand
même 10 ans maintenant que je me suis
rendu compte qu'à côté de toutes ces
photos de reportage j'avais fait
beaucoup de photos d'enfants de mère et
d'enfants de famille qui étaient hors
reportage alors est-ce que c'est parce
que je suis une femme je n'en sais rien
ouis c'était un sujet qui vous touchait
euh personnellement et euh d'accord et
ensuite alors vous avez euh cessé ce
travail de de reporter et vous avez
cessé de parcourir le le monde et vous
êtes revenus ici dans les ivelines voilà
alors comment on s'occupe dans ces
cas-là quand on passe de d'une vie
pleine de de d'adrénaline d'action de
voyage de rencontre et qu'on arrive et
qu'on s'occupe de ces deux enfants et et
son mari un gros décalage j'étais tout
d'un coup femme à la maison non non mais
je me suis occupée des enfants d'abord
je men suis toujours un petit peu
occupée même quand je par en reportage
quand même mais bon c'est vrai qu'à
partir de la seconde il faut un peu plus
peut-être avoir l'œil sur eux et puis et
bien en restant un peu plus on va dire à
la maison j'ai eu envie d'aller voir La
Chaîne de l'Espoir dont j'avais croisé
on va dire un membre en 1988 et c'est
simplement 2006 que je suis retournée à
la Chaîne de l'Espoir pour me dire tiens
et si j'étais famille d'accueil alors on
va d'abord expliquer qu'est-ce que c'est
que la Chaîne de l'Espoir La Chaîne de
l'Espoir c'est une une une
association qui s'occupe d'opérer sur
place et aussi en France des enfants qui
ont en général des problèmes cardiaques
je dis en général parce que ça pe être
aussi des malformations du visage enfin
maintenant il faut un petit peu d'autre
chose d'accord et alors qui a monté
cette association c'est le professeur
Annan deoge qui est un grand cardiologue
et surtout qui a fait partie de de ces
médecins un peu fous Médecins du Monde
médecin MSF et Cera d'accord donc
lui-même opéit à l'étranger exactement
tout à fait d'accord et après il a
décidé de il était aussi après il a
opéré en France et c'est là où il a
décidé de que tous ces enfants qui les
les pauvres n'avaient rien demandé et
qui é dans des pays pauvres ouaisit pas
les opér de les faireenir en France et
de les opérer grâce à des médecins qui
opérent bien sr gratuitement grâce à des
familles d'accueil comme nous qui
accueillons ces enfants d'accord parce
que si on les opère pas ils meurent tout
simplement exactement d'accord donc on
leur offre une chance de vivreit voilà
donc c'est là où vous entrez en jeu si
je puux dire puisque vous vous êtes donc
proposé pour être famille d'accueil
alors comment ça s'est passé la première
fois la première fois j'ai d'abord eu un
enfant c'était une petite malienne ça
c'est très bien bien passé mais ça a été
très dur parce que c'était une petite
fille qui ne donnait rien et moi je
donnais beaucoup ça veut dire quoi don
rien ex et ben ça veut dire qu'elle
restait toujours comme ça un petit peu
un petit peu en retrait et donc ça a été
un petit peu dur moi qui donne
énormément j'ai trouvé ça un petit peu
vous êtes très dans dans le contact
exactement alors elle elle parlait pas
français elle parlait pas français elle
ne voulait pas parler français ah bon et
elle avait quel âge elle avait 8 ans
ouis et à partir de ce moment-là je me
suis dit plus jamais je prendrai un
enfant seul et maintenant je demande
j'ai pres je demande à avoir deux
enfants donc c'est chaque année deux
enfants d'un même pays d' plus ou moins
du même âge et par contre garçon ou
fille peu importe d'accord ok et alors
comment ça se passe concrètement vous
vous allez les chercher à l'aéroport et
après que alors à partir du moment où on
sait qu'ils vont arriver on a 3 semaines
avant on reçoit leur dossier donc déjà
c'est une petite excitation parce qu'on
voit leur nom et Cera il y a voilà il y
a des détails ENF qui sont qui sont
vraiment intéressant à connaîre on va
les chercher à l'aéroport et à partir du
moment où on va les chercher à
l'aéroport on les considère comme nos
enfants
d'accordend par d'enfan gravement
malades qui vont être opérés tout à fait
d'accord et ils sont opérés en général
une semaine après leur arrivé ah oui ça
va très vite sauf exception j'ai eu une
petite fille qui était tellement mal
qu'on a opéré d'urgence au bout de de
jours et qui va très bien aujourd'hui
d'cord donc en fait vous n'avez pas
vraiment le temps de faire connaissance
avant l'opération en c'est c'est voilà
et après vous récupérez un enfant qu'on
va LESISS 100 tout à fait ils vont ils
vont d'abord à l'hôpital après en maison
de repos et ensuite ils reviennent à la
maison et c'est complètement différent
quand ils arrivent c'était c'est C
frayant tout est nouveau et quand ils
reviennent de la maison de repos à ce
moment-là ils reviennent presque chez
eux et là les rapports sont totalement
différents en plus vous avez eu le temps
de faire connaissance j'imagine que vous
allez les voir tous les jours oui vous
vous êtes comme comme votre enfant quoi
vous dormiez à l'hôpital ou pas enant ça
m'est arrivé même de dormir par terre la
petite fille trouv ça normal parce qu'en
Afrique on dort par terre sûr moi j'ai
trouvé ça un petit peu dur mais j'aurais
je ne savais pas qu'on pouvait demander
à dupitan personne ne vous l'a proposé
non donc j'ai dormi par terre d'accord à
l'africaine exactement OK et est-ce
qu'il y a eu des des moments où ça s'est
un peu moins bien passé des moments un
peu délicats un peu un peu compliqués à
gérer en général ça ça s'est très bien
passé même lorsqu'on a eu par exemple un
petit iraakien qui était vraiment très
très malade qui était ce qu'on appelle
en position de squattine c'est-à-dire
pour que c'est-à-dire qu'il est resté
pendant 10 ans quasiment accroupi pour
que le de 0 à 10 ans oui enfin de 10 ans
de sa vie pardon ouais c'est ça oui on
va dire presque parce qu'il était
capable de marcher un peu mais de trois
pas et donc le fait d'être complètement
accroupi fait que le sang à ce moment-là
passe mieux dans le dans le corps et
après l'opération alors et quand il est
arrivé c'était un sauvage il était
effrayant coléreux sauvage et tout et
après l'opération cet enfant ben ça été
une deuxème naissence parce que tout
d'un coup il s'est rendu compte qu'il
pouvait marcher qu'il pouvait courir
extraordinaire d'accord d'accord ouais
c'est beau ça il s'est il s'est vraiment
apprévoisé il est reparti avec un grand
sourire et et c'était c'était magnifique
quoi quand on en parle encore ouais
c'est une belle histoire ouais et je me
demandais alors la séparation parce que
vous vivez quand même des choses bon ça
ça dure quand même 2 mois très intense
il y a des liens évidemment qui se crée
vous êtes un peu leur j'ai cru entendre
une fois leur maman blanche la maman
blanche la maman blanche ça dépend parce
que quand j'ai des Iraquiens c'est autre
chose non c'est pas la maman blanche
mais bon voilà et c'est pas trop
douloureux de de quitter ces petits
enfants comment ça se pass en de mots
c'est vrai que c'est c'est pas facile
parce qu'on vit des choses extrêmement
fortes la peur au départ l'angoisse de
l'opération après c'est merveilleux puis
pouf tout d'un coup ça s'arrête et bien
tout le monde pleure à l'aéroport
d'accord bon ensuite je je récupère ma
liberté c'est pas mal non plus c'est pas
mal non plus donc on est un petit peu
triste bien sûr mais bon c'est comme ça
toute façon ils sont pas c'est le but du
jeu et on n pas là pour les adopter et
vous avez des nouvelles
quelquefois pas toujours pas toujours
mais de temps en temps on arrive à avoir
des nouvelles ça être sympa ça plaisir
ah oui ou oui h d'accord euh bon ça
c'est une partie de votre vie et là
récemment vous avez découvert un nouvel
univers qui est le monde du handicap
sportif oui hein comment ça alors c'est
c'est un peu un univers àart que
malheureusement on connaît peut-être pas
très bien donc moi je vous propose de
regarder une petite vidéo sur des des
sportifs Olympiques qui sont en fauteuil
qui sont handicapés et qui participent à
un match de rugby fauteuil donc déjà on
va voir comme ça on saura de quoi on
parle voilà
d'accord r Salem 42 ans et je pratique
le rugby
fauteuil je pratique du basket en
fauteuil à l'origine et on est venu me
chercher pour pratiquer le rugby
fauteuil avec l'équipe de
France dans cette discipline c'est un
sport collectif c'est un sport de de qui
est assez violent et il y a un petit peu
les bases du basket du football
américain du rugby tout ça qui est un
petit peu
mélangé effectivement c'est assez
impressionnant ces match c'est c'est
presque violent c'est violent on
croirait des gladiateurs je trouve parce
qu'ils ont le droit de se taper ils
n'ont pas le droit de se toucher au
niveau du corps mais par contre les
fauteuils qui sont très carénés ou on a
vu des des fauteuils spéciaux voilà et
vous alors comment s'est passé cette
rencontre et bien j'ai rencontré Riad
sadem qui est un grand sportif qui a
fait pas mal de de jeux olympiques qui
est un qui est très handicapé puisque il
n'a pas de jambes de de mains il a juste
une petite main à à droite ou à gauche
je sais plus et puis un moignon de
l'autre côté enfin vraiment très très
handicapé par cont de naissance mais dès
qu'il est sur ses jambes d'acier alors
là c'est un espèce de grand gaillard
absolument extraordinaire et on a eu une
rencontre dans un endroit absolument
improbable et on a sympathisé et ça m'a
intéressé de découvrir un petit peu son
univers donc vous avez rencontré ce ce
champion olympique Riad Salem et
qu'est-ce qui vous a fasciné chez lui
qu'est-ce qui vous a interpellé d'abord
son charisme son charisme tout à fait et
d'autre part parce qu'il se bat
énormément pour intégrer le handicap
dans notre monde de valide voilà donc ça
son son combat m'a vraiment intéressé je
me suis dit que j' j'aimerais bien
l'aider je ne sais pas encore vraiment
comment si ce n'est que j'ai quand même
un projet avec lui c'est de faire un
livre sur sa vie sur ses combats et je
voudrais que ce livre soit justement un
livre d'espoir parce que les les tous
ces gens que j'ai rencontré pendant les
matchs de rugby et de basket fauteuil
sont des gens absolument incroyable qui
sont vraiment totalement abîmés
physiquement et qui ont une joie de
vivre ils sont extraordinaires voilà et
je voudrais que ce livre soit un espoir
pour tous ces gens qui en ce moment sont
en train de se battre parce que ils
viennent d'apprendre qu'ils seront
handicapés à vie ou ils sont en train de
vivre justement toutes ces séances de
kiné si dur pour essayer de récupérer
quelque choseacord ouais et ce qui ce
qui frappe d'ailleurs quand on voit ces
vidéos c'est la joie de vivre finalement
ils ont une vraie vie entière
ils y vont à fond ils prennent des
risques il plaisantent ils on des
plaisanteries sur leur monde qui est qui
sont vraiment rigolotes oui oui oui tout
à fait fait bon donc ce livre en
chantier tout à fait voilà mais alors ça
sera pas votre premier livre parce que
vous avez déjà écrit un livre en écrit
de livres j'ai fait deux livres vous
avez fait mais moi j'ai envie de parler
de celui-là s'il vous plaît ça c'est
écrit il y a des textes bien sûr mais il
y a surtout de magnifiques photos oui
hein et finalement c'est ce dont on
parlait tout à l'heure ces photos que
vous aviez pris hors travail lors de vos
voyages ces photos de de femmes et
d'enfants absolument magnifiques vous
les avez condensés condensé je sais pas
si c'est le bon mot bon bref je les ai
rassemblé dans un livre de cœur qui est
vendu au profit de la Chaîne de l'Espoir
parce que j'ai voulu m'engager justement
un peu plus au niveau de la Chaîne de
l'Espoir ce livre vous l'avez édité
vous-même parce que je crois que le but
c'était que tout qui est pas de
d'interférence et que tout l'argent
aille directement à la Chaîne de
l'Espoir exactement et voilà donc la
Meille sol c'était de vous créer votre
maison d'édition édition montbello
toutit et de d'éditer ce ce magnifique
livre et ben écoutez merci je vous
remercie c'était vraiment super
intéressant et puis bah à bientôt pour
ce livre sur Riad qui va nous ouvrir des
des champs extraordinaire et on va
découvrir comme ça un monde différent
j'espère mais bien sûr c'est ce que je
souhaite en tout cas mais ça sera le cas
j'en suis
sûr